welcome back to special report take a
look at the map in ukraine what's
happening
same thing different day it seems like
there's a little bit of russian movement
here in the south a lot of bombardment
continues in these places around
kharkiv and especially in the suburbs
around kiev as this russian movement
continues as we've seen for many days
to try to encircle the capital city what
we have seen is significant ukrainian
pushback
here in the city of brevari right here
it's just outskirts about 16 miles from
the center of kiev take a look at this
video this is a column and you
referenced it in jennifer griffin's
piece getting hit
by anti-tank weapons look at this this
is a russian
effort to take uh this street this area
just outside kiev getting attacked by
ukrainian forces now we'll go back to
the map
and take you to another place which is
right
on the other side this is about
45 miles as the crow flies
outside the city of kiev and another
major ukrainian defense move take a look
at the video
this is again anti-tank anti-armor
weapons likely a javelin taking out
armor right right there
and you can see it on the on the camera
it's happening
all the time there's 17 000 plus
javelins and stingers that have gone
into this country this is a look at the
roads in ukraine all throughout and
there are efforts to get refugees now in
the millions out of the country now it's
a more than 300 miles from keeve to the
polish border four five hour trip now
taking 16 18 hours we're told and it's
just a flood of refugees here's levive
down here that is where lucas tomlinson
is again tonight with the effort of the
human chain to get aid into
this area hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else